welcome back to the edge with your boy
Michael Parson live in your Bleacher
Report app and I know you probably have
a lot of questions and a lot of comments
about the game so drop them in the chat
and I'll respond during the show um my
biggest takeaway from the game is
obviously we couldn't stop the run flat
out and simple um a lot of Cowboys fans
have questions about how we play home
and versus away and they're very valid
points and accusations because of our
track record so far versus us at home
and that's that way um I don't really
have an answer for you but I just know
that we need to play better we need to
get better there's no excuses obviously
after a loss like that we just couldn't
stop the run flat out and simple um not
getting into detail who's fault who's
blame it was a collective group but what
I'm seeing is like what I understand is
like everyone just waits for the Cowboys
to lose um I saw multiple analysts
people who are fake analysts who somehow
got jobs on TV saying there goes your
boy like it's almost to the point where
it's like almost sick that they're
waiting for another a former players are
waiting for other current players to
fail so that way they have something to
talk about and I mean it's not even to
just get into names I mean I feel like
at this point you kind of know who you
are and it's like oh there he is that's
the person we've been waiting for and
it's like why do you want a person to
lose so bad as a former player and as a
current player I feel like you like I'm
a fan of the game right whether I'm
playing Josh Allen or whoever at the end
of day I don't want to see Josh Alin
hurt I don't want to see him fail I want
him to see continue his career um at the
end of the day obviously when we're
playing and we're lining up I'm trying
to beat him right but it seems that a
lot of people are just waiting for uh
people would have fail and then you get
into the criticism and I seen a lot of
people saying well how do we want to use
my like a we shouldn't um you we should
use him more off the ball well guess
what there was times where they mov me
off the ball and then y'all were like
well why isn't he rushing the passer why
isn't he doing this it's almost like you
can't like I said teams will always play
us differently Josh all him averaging 30
to 40 passing attempts so obviously we
didn't think he was going to come out
and run it the whole game and run
consecutive plays over and over again so
I mean that's obviously not part of the
game plan but it's almost like you can't
always get everything you want you you
want someone to rush and then you want
someone to stop the run be off the ball
it's like you can't you can't do
everything and obviously it's easy to
point because certain groupings is going
to be in certain Personnel it's a lot of
giveaways what coverages you can be in
is very predictable in NFL it's hard to
win an NFL at the end of day it's hard
to play perfectly weekend and weeking
out every day and that's just a reality
we seen it out of multiple great teams
and we never said the bills were were a
weak team we always said they were a
really good team they just weren't
producing to the level they they should
be and they produced at that level back
toback weeks they arguably could have
beat the Eagles they arguably could have
beat a lot of teams they beat the Chiefs
I mean they're beating good teams the
bills have always been good it was just
the turnovers the beating themselves but
they never no one ever said the bills
were bad and that's just the reality of
it James Cook had a career night bought
out you know and that was the first time
we gave up over a 100 rushing yards to a
player before uh and that's just reality
I mean Josh even said I felt like a kid
that didn't do anything in the class and
in in the class project and still got a
a Josh Allen didn't beat the there was a
great team win you know he was seven for
15 four seven passes might have been
dropped back and other were play action
and things like that like they didn't
want to drop back the CR front they they
they made a goal and they got up on the
lead um we beat ourselves with three
crucial penalties that led to points
that continue drives and so forth but at
the end of the day we just got to play
better we're going to have to get better
um we got opportunity next week to go
out and play the Dolphins and win that
game and that's all that matters to me
um it's just howke bounce back after you
get smacked in the mouth you know what
I'm saying everything's all good when
you're on a high horse and you're going
up the mountain and everything's good
but it's time to get back to work and
get better cuz at the end of the day we
may have clenched a playoff spot but it
does not matter cuz we're going to have
to travel we're going to have to be Road
Warriors we will not be the number one
seed we're going to have to get better
at the end of the
day but let's get across the league Jake
Browning another Victory beat the
Vikings in OT 27-24 the Bengals are
currently the number six se in AFC
playoff picture J Brown is hooping I
seen he had another drug
test um
after after the field goal Jake Browning
got caught screaming at the camera
saying they should have never cut me I
mean we're kind of seeing this out of
quarterbacks who's being traded
quarterbacks who's getting picked up um
we kind of seen the Josh dobs but my
question is how long would this last can
Jake continue to play play at this level
there were like a couple weeks ago he
hasn't played in multiple years now he's
dominated NFL has a lot of great talent
around him with Jamar Chase T Higgins
Joe Mixon Tyler boy
can he contain this right it it'll be
very interesting to see how this how
this goes and how long can the Bengals
keep rolling without Joe Bro that
defense is really stepping up and what
would that Jamar if Jamar Chase is out
how long is he out for so it this is
going to be very interesting to see I I
don't think this would be another Josh
job situation but Tom will tell um cuz
he's beaten a great Jags team he's just
beat uh a pretty good Vikings team um so
it it'll be very interesting to see
getting into the Browns against the
Bears the end of the Bears Browns was
wild um David nju had a wild reaction
himself after the end of the game I mean
look how close Mooney was to having this
like like that is
nuts like Mooney was so close to ending
that game
um uh he said I damn near myself dog
like that's nuts like I actually saw a
stat where the Browns have had 10 plus
over 10 games where they were leading 10
plus going to the fourth quarter not one
so this Browns team is a really good
team they just have to finish games
better I think at the end they will they
will be transitioning especially going
into next year with the draft cap they
have and getting more players and they
still having a lot of money in free
agency I mean the Bears is really going
to be a very good team the Bears is
going to be a legitimate playoff team
next year I truly believe I think they
can beat they can win out in the NFC
North obviously um beating the they beat
the Packers I mean they're be I mean I
think this team can legitimately be uh a
a top playoff team as of next year with
Justin Fields I think Justin Fields is
coming along a lot of way and I think
they're going to keep adding Talent keep
getting better and they're going to be a
legitimate playoff team um especially
once they learn how to finish games off
um Can Joe flacko continue to have the
Browns PS for the playoffs we always
knew the Browns was a well coached team
obviously with DeShaun Watson out chub
out um and players like that the Browns
defense is still there the Browns
defense is still there they can still
make the playoffs they can still make
the run but how far can a Super Bowl
champion Joe flacko take them um
obviously didn't have a great game
against the uh bears but can he do that
can he play like he did the week before
at a high level and can he how far can
he take this team because when you got
miles gar you got Denzel Ward um you got
Martin Emerson you got Grant delpit all
these great players is Darius Smith on
that def defense uh it could go very far
and I think this is a very good team
miles Garrett made comments about the
refs in his postgame press conference
after the JS game he was find 25,000 he
says he stands by what he says and hope
has a positive impact at the end of the
day and and I'm saying this right they
do not like it's almost like the players
just got to shut up and play because no
matter what we say no matter what we
complain about we're not getting calls I
mean you we can't buy a holding call you
can't buy any in this league the rest
are going to call what they want um the
review is BS I mean it's just it's just
unpredictable what they're doing and
then when you go out and speak they find
you when you go out and play what
football is they find you so it does not
matter what you do almost in the NFL
they are going to find you uh Damonte KZ
just got fined well not even fined just
lost money and just got suspended for
the rest of the season for making a
legal hit what is that man supposed
supped to do his head did not hit he put
his shoulder into M uh Michael pitman's
chest and he just got suspended for the
rest of the year for a throw that Garner
menu make he's trying to make a flying
catch is a player just supposed to let
another player catch the ball what is
the point of playing defense anymore in
NFL if you cannot make hits I did not
think that was a bad hit I didn't not
think it was a dirty hit he made a play
where he thought he could and it's
unfortunate Michael Pitman got hurt
that's completely unfortunate but as Tom
Brady said and people after people again
they are making it almost impossible to
play defense in NFL I mean you look at
the play with jron kurur when on that
second and the player drops the ball he
doesn't put his head down his shoulder
doesn't go in he comes on top of the
player after he drops the ball and he
gets a unnecessary roughness it's just
like how can you play football in the
NFL right now it's almost completely
like we're in a sport where they make it
so hard to play defense and so easy to
play offense you see Josh Allen he's 66
240 people call him a running back he
could flop and get a defensive uh uh a a
roughing the passer it's just like what
do you supposed to do with some of this
stuff and I mean the late slides the
time up they they they they run all the
way into the point you're about to
contact them in the slide there needs to
be a gap in between the slides I mean
they make it so hard and then some times
they don't even slide they just keep
running when you think they're going to
slide they make it so hard to play
defense uh and it's across the league
it's across the league and it's and it's
obvious it's obvious but yet I see time
and time again you could be rushing a
tackle and a chipper could come
Blindside hit you but let you do that to
an offensive player or you return to
touchdown and it's illegal it's just
like where is the space for defense
where is the space where is there going
to be breathing room I mean it and and
it's terrible right now it's honestly
terrible I think the NFL needs to make
adjustments they need to make um they
need to make like it's almost like
football is turning into basketball
right football is supposed to be some
phys a physical sport where it's man on
man and at the end of the day it's
supposed to go
into you know whatever happens happens
right if you can't handle the sport
don't play it right our viewership don't
want to see flags for flops and things
like like this isn't basketball I'm not
calling basketball players you know
anything but they do a lot of fake
charges flopping I see so many people
act like they got hit in the face and
stuff like that I mean obviously I can't
go into no recck league with these
players because they'll call foul for
almost everything like it's just it's
almost it's like embarrassing the sport
and I know maybe that's why oldheads in
the league said man I couldn't play in
these times I couldn't do this in these
times and it's understandable they're
changing the game where it's just such
an offensive League where you just can't
do anything I mean anything but that
that's my piece on it I mean if they
change it they change it if they don't I
don't we just got to play and just keep
keep doing what we're trying to do and
that's just contain these great players
and just can't hit them you just you
could do everything in football but
can't hit them I think football would be
flag football in about 5 10 years I mean
honestly we're we're penalizing and
taking money from people's families for
playing the way the game should be
played you know I think if anything
people like Ryan Clark Troy palalo Ray
Lewis these great players who we who we
loved for the way they played the game
if they played in today's day they might
be kicked out of the league like is that
like is that not insane like the Ronnie
Lots the Ed Reeds like the people the
Shawn Taylor's why did people love Shawn
Taylor because of his energy how he he
loved the game he used to come down and
kill people kill people but yet now we
we're we're we're we're basically saying
we don't want that anymore we don't want
those great players that we constantly
talk about the the the people that we
love the people that we put in the Hall
of Fame and we cherish we don't want
them people to be those guys no more we
don't want that we want this new era of
BS that we're calling it it's New Era
this new era is crazy the people that we
and it's almost like you got to be
mindful of trying to hit a player or
touch a player because you don't want to
get fine you don't want and like you see
players coming off on could be sacks
because they're pumping the ball and you
don't want to hit a quarterback late you
don't want to cost your team it it's
just ridiculous I mean just outright
ridiculous but let's just move on um the
Ravens clinch a playoff spot and then
Sunday night Sunday night went over the
Jags the Ravens CL cler spot believe
they're the first in the AFC uh I don't
think people were talking about Lamar
Jackson season enough Lamar Jackson has
3100 yards 17 TDS seven receptions the
Ravens are 11 and three obviously
playing great defense defense is playing
lights out um and they're they're doing
this uh Brock P's currently the the
favorite um 3700 y
3795 yards 29 touchdowns 7 interceptions
the 49ers 11-3 um and he's obviously the
MVP favorite right now does the Ravens
and 49ers on Christmas have an MVP
implications um I don't believe it's MVP
complications I think right now um Brock
party is obviously because of last week
uh he's a clear favorite but I do we I
think this is the type of game that uh
people are waiting to see obviously with
the Ravens having that uh great defense
uh and who they have over there and the
way they play it'll be very fun and see
interesting to watch the game game I
think this is going to be a very good
game um and obviously see what Brock pry
does against the best AFC team cuz right
now people we will arguably say the
49ers are the best team in the NFL right
now um if if you're speaking numbers
wise analytically everyone's healthy and
who who they all have so it's going to
be a great game and uh super excited to
see but uh the 49ers pass rush is just
going to have to find a way to contain
Lamar Jackson um and it's going to be a
very good one uh super uh excited to
watch that game and uh let's take some
final questions from the chat and then
we'll get into cowboys Dolphins game how
much did y'all Miss Jonathan hakins last
game obviously we always when we're
missing a player it's uh it's it's truly
terrible it's it's sufferable I mean
Hank is going to come back and be a
great player for us um no matter what
did everyone having the summer bug
impact the game I wouldn't say everyone
uh it impacted the game but obviously
when you're dealing with a lot of stuff
and people are B in illness Gilly was
out all week and things like that
obviously impacts of how you uh
structure the game who's out there and
uh the people that's getting the Reps
and the looks and things like that and
it's often say holding happens on every
play so how often should a flag really
be thrown I think when it's blatant I
think when I had that Rush against the
center you got to call it that's third
down I mean I believe I'm getting a sack
if this guy's not pulling on me draping
my arm I can't even get both my arms up
I'm clearly past him you can't be
blocking me behind me um that's my
thought about it uh and that's just
something that has to be called and and
that's a and that's a crucial down and
situation where it should be called um
is it tough playing in cold weather when
you get used to playing indoors at home
I don't believe so I played at Penn
State bro like I'm I'm from up North I
played in Pennsylvania where we played
District games and State Games and 30
degree weather winds all that stuff uh
it really has no impact on me uh
healthwise my knee is perfectly fine um
rehab things like that to get back in
place I see Henry Jersey in wall is he
still a top five RB especially if he
leaves the Titans um I believe so I
think Derrick Henry is a product of his
system right now um I mean if you look
at that game people are flying through
the line going unblocked busting through
double teams and uh they just not
preciate him this you got think uh the
Titans is in a whole rebuild will L just
got hurt again he was playing at a great
level um they're line they're trying to
get their guys back together they they
let uh they let Taylor lean go a couple
other guys go so he's playing behind a
bunch of backups and uh you know things
like that so I think Derrick Henry
definitely needs a better look how would
you feel about your team selling 45 Cent
tickets like the Panthers did yesterday
um you know that's just happens when
you're not playing at a really good
level and you're not playing well uh you
know it it sucks and that's the reality
of it and I don't think Atlanta has a
lot of fan base that's traveling right
now for them um so it it it sucks you
know um it it's terrible to see but you
know that's part of it you know you got
to play well for people to want to come
see you um what are you getting the team
for Christmas I'm thinking about getting
the team hocus I'm a big hocus guy I've
been trying to actually hocus if you're
watching this I've been trying to
partner with you guys to get custom
Cowboys hocus for the dline room and a
bunch of other guys on the team so if
you see this please contact me I've been
team hoker for a while I actually got my
hokers on right now you know I got the
Hoka slippers on you know so hokers if
you out there you know just hit me up
baby I got my hokers on I'm a big hocus
guy I wear hocus everywhere almost uh
just because for me I like to be
comfortable especially when I go to
amusement parks and I'm walking all day
hokers take a lot out on my knees and
stuff like that so if you got feet
problem hey go get you some hokers for
sure about the Dolphins how would the
Cowboys defense be prepared for
two-headed monster the backfield that
Miami has um that's just just we just
got to go out there and play at the end
of the day uh what happen happened last
week you got to have that next mentality
and get ready to ball out um how
disappointed will you be if Tyreek Hill
can't play um not too disappointed
honestly Tyreek Hill obviously he's a
monster of a player but obviously his
health is way more important than any
record or anything he's trying to do uh
Tyreek Hill is gonna be great no matter
what and if he don't break the record
this year I'm pretty sure he's going to
break it before he retires because
that's the type of player he is he's a
hell of a player he's super exciting to
watch and I mean uh you know I just want
him to get healthy cuz I know he's going
to help his team make a great playoff
run you know that's it for the questions
obviously we got a hell of a matchup me
and Tyreek been talking all year all
along um it it's going to be great to
see uh you know in a great matchup
obviously uh Tyreek I know he's been
waiting for this that's probably why I
said out last week I doubt he misses
this game even though um he's dealing
with that ankle injury but he's a hell
of a player uh this matchup is both two
playoff teams two playoff teams that
could Poss we see each other uh in in
the in the in the final you know
obviously so it's going to be a great
matchup great to get uh great game super
excited uh you know it it's going to
come it's going to be a battle you know
obviously the Dolphins have one of the
best receiving cours if not the best
receiving court but wide on tyreq in the
league and a great running back Duo moer
has the most
rbds uh he had I
mean uh acne he was hooping before his
knee injury and I mean he is going I
mean I mean it's unlimited speed out
there it's going to be a great game uh
and and it's going to be like that uh
and for the humidity in Miami let y'all
know uh we in Texas baby don't get
hotter than Texas we're used to the I'm
pretty much used to the Heat and the
cold by now um been in here for three
years and uh being a PA my whole life so
you know it's going to be uh very
exciting um so uh and I can't wait to be
out there so Cowboys Nation uh I know
know that was a rough one and I know
that's not something y'all wanted to see
but we're going to need everybody
support come out to the Sunny Side of
Miami Florida or Fort Lauderdale
wherever the stadium is and come and
support your Cowboys we need y'all we
need to make this feel like a home game
we got come up come up and show out at
the end of day and that's simple you and
that's just how it's going to be I want
to thank everyone for tuning in to the
edge with your boy Michael Parsons I see
y'all next week um and that's it
peace